Justin Timberlake singing folk music I
really didn't think I'd ever see that
day inside Llewyn Davis is directed by
the Coen brothers and stars Oscar Isaac
Carey Mulligan Justin Timberlake and
John Goodman this is a story all about
how my life got flipped turned upside
down sorry I got in my head all of a
sudden this is a story of a man named
Lewin Davis no he's a folk singer in the
60s and he's kind of navigating the
music scene of that time trying to
figure out a way to make a living doing
what he loves which is folk music and we
follow him for a week of his life and in
this week we see him go through various
different hardships and trials and
tribulations as he tries to figure out a
way to survive now I'm a big fan of the
Coen brothers I like quite a bit of
their films they have such a terrific
way of writing and of course directing
their films look great Roger Deakins is
my favorite cinematographer they use him
quite often unfortunately he was
unavailable for this movie so the
cinematography isn't quite up to par
with most of their other films even
though it's still very good nevertheless
this is a very good movie a very
well-written movie a very sharply funny
movie it's the kind of movie that really
surprises you with its humor you'll be
watching a scene that you think is so
beautiful important and it's supposed to
be like this very heartwarming scene and
it just hits you with this extremely
dark humor that very much so surprised
me quite often in this movie it's
extremely funny but it's also got a very
sweet dramatic tone to it where you
really start to care for this guy LuAnn
Davis to the point where you just want
to see this guy find some little shred
of something that he can survive on
because he is constantly crapped upon on
this movie like everything goes wrong
for him he can't seem to catch a break
anywhere and Oscar Isaac is so good here
this is one of my favorite things about
going to the movies when you see an
actor or an actress who you've seen in
the past and you've liked him or her and
other things but then you see that one
role where you're just like wow this is
a serious talent and this guy is great
in this movie he delivers the comedic
lines perfectly I mean he's got just the
right tone he captures just the right
essence that his character should but he
also is so terrific with the singing and
the guitar playing that was something
that really took me by surprise but he's
actually very talented and that's saying
something for me because I'm 100%
a folk music fan I will never just kick
back and listen to folk music but he did
such a good job with these songs they're
all very storytelling songs you know
where the story is told from beginning
to end and I like songs like that but as
I said I'm not really a big fan of folk
music but the way he sang it the way he
played it in the way the songs were
written really made it something that I
didn't mind listening to and that could
be something for some viewers because
there's quite a bit of it in this movie
you know but it's not like that
folk music that you just you can't quite
stand because look I know that there are
fans of that type of genre out there I'm
not one of them but the actors do such a
good job of making those scenes where
they do have to sing entertaining and
the way the Coen brothers directed this
movie it all just feels so smooth and
laid-back in fact that's all I've ever
heard about the Coen Brothers sets is
that they're so laid back and relaxed
and that no one ever feels stressed when
they make their films and you just feel
as if you are watching two guys who are
so amazingly relaxed and well prepared
and who is a staple of Coen Brothers
movies John Goodman he shows up and
you're like okay that's John Goodman
awesome
love that guy he's funny he's a good
actor and then every line out of his
mouth is just pure gold this isn't my
favorite Coen Brothers movie though it's
an extremely somber film you can
actually watch the film and start to
feel kind of bad for a while because
it's just beat down after beat down
after beat down and you just start to
feel like I can't take watching this guy
get constantly pummeled emotionally in
life anymore
but then there's also a very harsh
realism to that because I don't have
personal experience being a musician who
can't seem to get work but I do know
what it's like to be involved in art and
want that art to be out there for people
to enjoy but not quite be able to do it
or not quite be able to get to that
point where I can actually have people
experience it and enjoy it and so in
that way I really related to this
character now typically the Coen
Brothers movies have very strange
endings unconventional endings I won't
spoil it I won't say anything I won't
even hint at anything all I'll say is
that it's a thinker you know when I left
the theater not quite sure how to feel
about it but this is definitely the kind
of film that requires multiple viewings
to enjoy and a lot of their films are
like
it is a very good film that should be
seen by anyone who loves movies I'm
gonna give it a B+ so guys what is your
favorite Coen Brothers movie mine kind
of always is switching between The Big
Lebowski and No Country for Old Men she
kidnapped herself man new has come
to light thanks a lot for watching guys
and as always if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]